harlem nord de manhattan depuis peu une
armée de mormons a envahi les rues de
cet ancien ghetto blacks
aujourd'hui ces missionnaires qui
considère ce appartenir à l'église
originelle de jésus-christ arpente le
bitume à la conquête de nouveaux membres
parmi ses cols blancs politique est la
première femme noire du quartier a
intégré l'église chrétienne baptisée les
saints des derniers jours ont été bons
quand les gens pas si je leur donne
cette carte
certains apprennent et d'autres folies
est né ici harlem après plusieurs
dépressions 7 auprès des mormons qu'elle
a trouvé une seconde famille
pourtant cette église qui revendique
être dirigée par un prophète vivant a
longtemps été perçue comme raciste est
considéré les blacks comme
spirituellement inférieur les gens ne
pouvaient pas comprendre pourquoi j'ai
fait ce que j'ai fait c'est vrai qu'ils
ont été durs avec moi mais je leur dis
que ce n'est pas parce que j'ai rejoint
cette église que j'ai oublié d'où je
venais
aux etats unis les mentalités ont évolué
à tel point qu harlem est devenu le
nouveau terrain de chasse des mormons
objectif remplir les bancs et les
caisses de l'église pour douglas le
chapon qui suis poli sur chacun de nos
tournage
l'intégration de son église n'a pas été
facile dans le quartier blacks quand on
a voulu construire une chapelle dans
harlem
il a eu beaucoup d'oppositions dans le
quartier les gens se méfiait de notre
église de notre religion et ne voulait
rien faire avec nous heureusement les
mormons ont leur botte secrète sisters
dick et la black qui connaît tout le
monde ici qu'est ce que vous venez juste
nous rendre visite vous n'avez rien à
perdre
lui il est intéressé normaux était un
prophète qui vivait aux états unis juste
ici sur ce territoire vivait il ya deux
mille ans si tu montre de l'intérêt tu
fait le premier pas et après c'est gagné
aux etats unis l'église mormone est
encore critiquer mais reconnu en france
elle est généralement perçue comme une
secte mais grâce à des missionnaires
comme polis l'église tourne déjà plus de
13 millions de membres dans le monde et
déjà plus de 1000 harlem en moyenne ont
fait huit à dix baptême par mois donc
oui on est très occupé ils sont très
occupés
pauli est sans emploi depuis ses récents
problèmes de santé elle consacre tout
son temps libre à l'église là devant la
maison de dieu elle se confesse
aujourd'hui les relations avec ses
frères blanc sont au beau fixe mais ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas
il me disait que je ne pouvais pas faire
partie des leur groupe
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je les ai
ressenti au début je ne me suis jamais
sentie accepté
personnes venues vers moi mais je ne me
suis jamais forcément pendant 25 ans
peut lier les rares mormons de harlem se
sont rendus dans une simple salle pour
célébrer leur office mais aujourd'hui la
communauté a bâti une nouvelle église
plus de 3000 m² pour ce nouveau royaume
en plein harlem
il y a cinq sages ici mais pour
l'instant on en utilise que 4 le
cinquième est toujours en construction
pour les activités
c'est là que ça se passe on est dans la
chapelle au quatrième garder ici c'est
le terrain de basket ball pour appâter
les jeunes blacks du quartier les
mormons n'ont pas lésiné sur les moyens
un terrain de basket au sein même de
l'édifice religieux pour construire
cette église hors norme
le prophète a dépensé sans compter le
financement pas de problème
l'église a la solution tous les mois on
paie une cotisation
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on donne 10
% de tous nos revenus à l'église
oui c'est ce qu'il demande mais on donne
ce qu'on peut quant au membre encore
sceptique le discours est bien rodé
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un trouve que cette règle
n'est pas juste on lui conseille de
s'adresser directement à dieu
lors de la prière notre père nous sommes
reconnaissants pour nous retrouver chez
ceux indiqués et pour nous rendre plus
forts comme souvent le dimanche matin
avant la messe poli reçoit les
missionnaires pour un simple petit
déjeuner ses jeunes amis ont quitté leur
famille pour effectuer leur service
religieux coût de la formation 400
dollars par mois
tout bénef pour l'église et surtout pour
son prophète on est missionnaire 24
heures sur 24 sept jours sur sept on
donne deux ans de notre vie on laisse
tout derrière nous on n'a pas le droit
de parler avec nos familles on peut
juste envoyer un mail ou une lettre par
semaine pas de téléphone
j'ai pas vu ma famille depuis 17 mois
ils sont un peu comme mes jeunes frères
et soeurs ça me fait plaisir de faire ça
pour eux ils sont là pour deux ans
sarenza ils ont besoin qu'on s'occupe
d'eux ça va calmer je me sens
responsable
retour à l'église
aujourd'hui pas de messe mais une
retransmission télé mondial en direct de
salt lake city
cette ville de l'utah dans l'ouest
américain et la mecque des mormons à
l'écran le prophète daumas manson 16e
président de l'église mormone
à ses côtés la chorale uniquement
composée de blancs mais ici à harlem
la moitié de l'assistance et noir quand
je suis rentré chez les mormons ma vie a
complètement changé la personne que vous
voyez maintenant on n'a rien à voir avec
celle que j'étais avant avant j'étais
seul et les mormons ne compte pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
les voies du seigneur sont toujours
pénétrable à d'autres communautés plus
de blancs plus de noirs la seule couleur
qui compte c'est le verre celui du
dollar
prochaine cible les asiatiques et tomasz
manson peut avoir le sourire il a tout
prévu jusqu'à faire traduire ces
prophéties hacker si la prochaine salle
de traduction ce sera pour les chinois
en attendant les chinois les mormons
sont en passe de réussir leur pari qu'il
semble loin le temps de la ségrégation
sur les bancs les frères noirs
commencent à rejoindre poli à l'heure où
les autres églises constate la désertion
de leurs ouailles
[Musique]